okay i think this works
um good afternoon
everyone for our first time in the
afternoon today we have uh
oh can you tell us about uh
differential privacy and robustness so
please take it away
all right thank you
let's get started um
so last couple of years i've been
thinking about the intersection between
uh differential privacy and robot
statistic
and um in the first half of the talk i'm
gonna present the first algorithm that
achieves
um
sound a little is it supposed to be this
okay
all right in the first half i'll present
the first algorithm that probably
guarantees uh difference our privacy and
robustness
while being efficient
and in the second half of the talk i'm
going to switch gears
and i'll look at an inefficient
algorithm computationally intractable
but an algorithm that achieves
optimal robustness and differential
privacy for a variety of problems and
this is joint work with my amazing
collaborators xiang liu who's my student
in europe um
is a former postdoc europe he's now at
google research
and champion
right
so
increasingly more and more systems are
trading big models on shared data so
think about something like federated
learning the premise there is that the
sensitive information that we shared is
not supposed to be revealed to someone
who only has access to the trained model
but as these models get bigger this kind
of uh membership inference attacks get
uh stronger so for example or easier for
example take a gpt-2 which is a
large-scale language model and if you
input a particular prefix or keywords
then it's going to start to output
unsensitive information about someone
who is in the training data the best
chance we have against protecting
against such membership inference attack
is either differential privacy or more
specifically dpsgd differential private
sgd and there what you did do is in
training these models when you're doing
an uh stochastic gradient update instead
of aggregating gradients from
multiplicity clients or data points you
do it in a different and private manner
so i'll go into details what it means
but for now i just want you to remember
that the best defense that we have
against
membership inference attack is
differentially private mean estimation
okay
another thing that can go wrong when
you're training on shared data
is that you cannot trust everyone who
gives you the data so it's easy for
someone to inject poison data like this
ones
so they flipped a couple of pixels and
labeled as a deer and if you train with
the neural network on a corrupted data
like this what's going to happen is that
at this time there'll be a back door
made in this trained model so whenever
whatever the background image is with
these triggers it's going to label this
image as a gear
and the best defense that we have
against
such a backdoor attack is using robust
statistics or robust destination
and the main idea there is that
if there was a successful backdoor
taking a trained neural network then
there must have been particular set of
neurons that are activated when it's
triggered by such water marks
so we did some experiment so on us
sci-fi 10 corrupted data set i trained
the deep 20 plus layer conventional
neural network what i'm showing you is i
cut the model in the middle which has
5000 neurons so every training data now
has a 5000 dimensional hidden layer
representation and i'm showing you this
for the
training data that has labeled dr which
is a target label
clean ones are in blue
poison word ones are in orange
okay and to show you i am projecting all
those down to six pca directions of
those five thousand uh directional
representations on the off diagonals of
the scatter plot for two each pair of
those directions and the diagonal or the
histogram for each of these directions
and if i don't tell you which one's blue
and which one's orange it's
hard for you to separate them out
because they are overlapping quite a bit
so i did another experiment where i took
the mean and the covariance of the blue
points and white and all of those data
points
okay afterwards what i see is this one
the blue ones now it's whitened and
centered just nicely circling any
direction you look at
and let me finish it right there chris
and the orange ones now shoot out in the
top pca directions
um
question i'm sorry
ah whitening means uh take the
covariance sigma and apply sigma
negative half
so that the covariance afterwards it's a
linear transform that gets you identity
covariance
the blue oh does the scale of the x's
are different yeah sorry it would be
exactly a circle if i
i couldn't do that sorry
i tried though
so if you scale the x's correctly it
will exactly circle
all right but here i was cheating
because i was using the covariance and
mean of the blue points we said no
suppose now
so what saves us is robust estimation of
the mean and the covariance
so i'm going to use the offshore tools
for robust estimation and apply to this
and what it does is that it gives me
mean and the covariance estimate of
majority of the points that i'm throwing
at the estimator which concentrates the
best
and just using it as is i get more or
less the same performance
and i'll get into the details of what it
does in later in this talk
but for now once you have it
even if i don't tell you the color you
can easily detect the poisoned ones
and train again on the filter. data set
and you get this as you have more poison
data your success rate without defense
goes up and up and up
but no matter where you are in this
operating point with this defense you
get almost you always completely remove
the back door
and this is we try this on every
state of the artifact or that we could
find codes for online or those we could
implement ourselves
so the poisoning was done with with or
without knowledge of your
diversification
[Music]
um
it was done by other people
they didn't know that we were going to
defend it this way
but those are very those come from very
simple to
it so you can change just one pixel
which is common attack this will be true
the sophisticated ones which use gans to
generate those the same is true so i
don't think you can
do anything much
by just knowing that
i'm going to do this defense the reason
is that i have no control of the model
they don't know the model because i can
just choose it today
a random model and then launch this
i'm the one who's new training they're
the ones who are giving me the training
data
so they cannot really do much
knowing that i'm gonna launch this
and i'll get to this after this talk
maybe happy to talk more but this is not
the main topic of this talk this is
motivation
but my work though was still a
motivation to tell you that we need to
protect against influence attacks and
poison attacks so we need both
differential privacy and robustness but
so far there's no efficient algorithm
that gives you that
so we're going to provide the first
algorithm that's efficient and gives you
approval guarantees for robustness and
differential privacy
and we're going to look at this problem
from the lines of statistical estimation
so you have a unknown distribution p
with the parameter theta oh
data is 101 you get niid data points and
you want to estimate data and when you
say you want to do it robustly you have
an adversary who inspects all of these n
data points chooses arbitrary alpha
fraction of the data point and replaces
it with arbitrary points
and the estimator knowing that this has
happened when i put a theta ahead which
is robust as middle of theta
and when you want privacy you have
another adversary who's going to inspect
the theta had you given me and tried to
check or test if a particular data point
let's say x3 was in the training data or
not
and the question we're asking
is how much do you have to pay more in
mean estimation for example for the
purpose of this talk
if i'm asking for robustness against
alpha corruption
or differential privacy which or the
work that has been done before me by
other people and where i come in is for
how much do you have to pay if you want
both
right it's the main estimation you get
nid samples and photo again proposing
this talk i'm going to assume these
samples are coming from sub gaussian
distributions with identity covariance
and i'll talk about you know how to do
other things later
um the minutes rate is of course square
dot b of n you achieve it by taking the
empirical mean
if you are doing robustly there has been
tremendous recent advances
i'm just gonna
talk about one which is by don hopkins
lee this is the fastest algorithm that
achieves
optimal accuracy under alpha corruption
of the data
and the reason i'm going to focus on
this one is that faster algorithms
access the data less
so what i want to do is make this
algorithm private and having less access
to the data makes it easier to make it
private and all of this will be
explained as we go along
but let's stick to robust mean
estimation in one dimension it's pretty
easy to do because here's your histogram
of sub-gaussian data let's say and the
adversity wants to move it to the right
then all she can do is take samples on
the left and just put it on the right
you could put it too far you'll be
detected as outliers it's a simple like
outlier detection like cutting off the
alpha tails left and right it's going to
achieve the optimal error of alpha or
alpha square root of log one of alpha in
this case
and in this talk i'm not going to care
about any constants and even the logs
i'll just throw it out if i don't want
to
and i don't want to go into details
but in high dimensions it gets tricky
because each sample can look perfectly
normal but they can conclude so then you
move them in quite a bit by let's say
alpha to the square root of d
alpha times square root of d
but notice that if such a you know
colluding attack has been launched then
it must be that the covariance has
changed quite a bit also so this maybe
you can use to detect such attacks and
remove them
indeed this can be made precise in the
next geometric mamma which tells us that
if the adversary moved the empirical
means significantly then it must be that
the covariance has to increase quite a
bit so this led to a series of advances
and algorithms known as filtering
algorithms the main idea is that every
iteration you check the covariance
and if it's large
then you look at the top one pca
direction project all your data points
onto the line and then filter out those
that contribute more to this covariance
and if you choose this algorithm
carefully you can ensure that every time
there'll be one data point removed so
that this terminates and every time on
average you'll be removing more
corrupted data points than clean data
points so when you're done
your covariance will be order alpha log
one of alpha
so that your total letter so the
algorithm goes like this you take a pca
and then you remove points that are
large and then you take a pca again and
maybe it points to this direction and
you remove large points some of them
might be clean data that might be
removed but you don't move them too many
of them
this you can show that you achieve the
extra error of alpha in this mean
estimation problem and you can show this
is optimal because if you look at two
gaussians with standard deviation one in
one dimensions which is alpha apart
let's say the mean is multiple power
then the total variation is only order
alpha meaning that an adversary
let's say even if you have all the
samples if you know the pdf you can
remove
alpha fraction of data from the one on
the left and move it to the right so i
cannot tell whether it's been done by
the adversary or if that's the original
one
so that's the best
minimax weight you can get on the alpha
correction for this problem is that your
extra
cost you pay is alpha
and maybe this is a good time
to pause if any questions
okay
all right
let's move on to the differential
privacy
right so differential privacy ensures
plausible deniability
by
making sure that even the
most powerful adversary who knows every
data point in the data set except for
one which let's say is yours
and if that adversary cannot tell from
the output of query whether you
participated in the database or not
so formally how it's done is that
consider two data sets sns prime which
only define one and three
and a particular let's say randomized
choreo output uh
query output
is called epsilon delta differentially
private if the output of a particular
data set s falls into set a is not too
different from the property that output
of another database that's only one
entry different falls into the same set
if these two um
probabilities are similar for if they
it's satisfied with small iso and delta
which means an adversary by looking at
the query output cannot test whether
it's coming from s or s prime
so you get plus or deny work
and how do you design a
different private mean estimator it's a
very simple case where the data set is
binary zero one you first compute let's
say the mean here
and then what you need to do is compute
what's called a sensitivity which is how
much you can shift the transfer by
switching one and three let's say from
zero to one in this case of course one
over n is your sensitivity and once you
get there then there's an easy way to
get a differential private output by
adding gaussian noise on top of it who's
proportional to the sensitivity over
epsilon
and doing this ensure that the pdfs are
already enough so that it satisfies the
dp conditions
the extra error here
due to this extra gaussian is other you
know sensitivity over epsilon which is
one over an epsilon
this is all good if you know the support
of the data set
and they're all bounded but in our
statical estimation they're not bonded
they with small priority they could be
anywhere
so what people do is they you first run
what's called private histogram on each
of the coordinates
and then you take two consecutive bins
the bin size has been already chosen
carefully take two consecutive bins that
are most occupied
and get a bonding box hypercube
and
project all the data that's outside onto
the inside of the cube
so now the most change you can make the
data point and this process is square
root of d so your sensitivity is square
d over n
and you add the gaussian
as i told you by sensibility over
epsilon so each coordinate now the error
you incur is sensitivity of one which is
um square root of d over n epsilon
and you have d coordinates overall you
pay d over m smart
so this is a dp min estimator i won't go
into the lower one for this one but
believe me there is a low one that
matches this upper bound so this is
minimized optimal d over s on n you pay
for asking for privacy
okay
right
now what do we want to do
finally what we do is that we want to
make this start from this filtering our
ingredients and make it private so that
we guarantee as soon as the differential
privacy and robustness against alpha
friction of
poisoning
so remember we start with this filtering
algorithm that i showed you before
and the first there are two challenges
in making it private the first challenge
is that in the worst case this algorithm
is going to run for other d
iterations and that's too many access to
data it happens because the adversary
can choose to put those corrupted points
and scatter them around in orthogonal
directions
and this algorithm only looks at one
direction at a time so maybe it can only
remove one data point at a time so it
takes other d
iterations to remove all of them
so we're going to resolve this by using
ideas from
this paper by jay lee dong hawkins about
quantum robust mean estimation and their
main idea is instead of looking at one
direction at a time gonna look at all
directions but weighted according to
this matrix exponential of the
covariance the larger covariance you
weighed more
as important and then you project all
the data points onto v so that you get a
scalar score quantum score for each data
point
and you can again run a random filter on
this one dimensional scores
removing those that have higher scores
with this
if beta is infinity beta is the one
that's controlling the temperature of
this matrix exponential it's infinity
then you cover the original
algorithm which looks at one pca
direction at a time beta is zero you
look at all the directions together you
know equally so you're just taking the
norm and removing the large gnome data
points
and for pretty chosen carefully chosen
beta you can show that using
matrix multiplicative weights and
analysis of the
regret you can show that the number of
iterations you need reduces dramatically
from order d
to log d squared
okay
so that's going to save us because now
we only have log accesses of data so we
don't have to pay as much in privacy
the next challenge you have is that the
1d filtering you use after you get the
quantum scores that people use
are highly sensitive in differential
privacy sense
and the reason
is that these algorithms independently
filter out each of these data points
with their quantum scores you flip a
coin for each one with a bias
proportional to its quantum score and
you decide to filter it out or not
if you do that you do this out you get
some filter set like this
and when you talk about differential
privacy you have to simulate the same
process with two different data sets one
exactly like this another one different
by one entry let's say like this one
and when you run the same process
this randomness cannot be coupled
because due to privacy you're not
supposed to know which data point
belongs to you know whoever so whatever
coin flip this data point was using you
cannot copy with this one
so what happens in the end is that it's
gonna randomly flip this coin separately
these two processes and you get widely
different outcome after filtering even
though original data set only differ by
one entry
so to control this
you have to couple these processes so we
propose a different way of filtering
which is a single threshold z drawn from
uniform between zero and
rho a lot of work has gone into
differentially privately calculating
this row has to satisfy the specific
conditions which i won't go into details
in this talk but once you have it then
you choose a uniform z let's say this
ratio this here and you filter whatever
is over z
and this process now can be coupled
because z has nothing to do with the
individual data points and you can show
that the sensitivity in terms of having
hamming distance between these two data
sets or preserved if they were different
in one entry at the filtering they are
different and most by one entry
no matter how many times you run this
filter
and that is kind of the main
key um insight in how you can make these
filtering algorithms private that's
different from any other
iterative difference or private
algorithms
with this you get an algorithm you first
run private histogram as i said before
just get a rough bounding box
and then you repeat
the filtering algorithm but with privacy
so you compute the covariance with
privacy you compute the mean with
privacy by adding gaussian noise and use
this to compute your quantum score
and then there's a part where you have
to get row from the
dp threshold algorithm which i didn't
tell you what it is once you get it you
get the single threshold filtering
algorithm
so
doing this we can show that
the
error you get at the end with alpha
corruption and i've shown that the
difference of privacy is going to be
well this part is the same because we're
looking upon the quantum robust minus
estimator which is that
and the extra privacy uh cost you pay is
now due to the 1.5 over m
so there's a square root of the
gap between the upper bound again and
then the low bound you would get by just
combining the lower bounds from these
two
all right and this is very fast because
it only takes about you know running one
svd over your data set to run the whole
thing
so where this square root of b of gap or
d to the 1.5 over epsilon n extra error
comes from is in computing the
covariance or the you know matrix
exponential covariance
differential privately
so when you have a covariance matrix
like those that we have
and you want to
um compute a difference of private
version of the queries matrix then you
need to add gaussian matrix with each
entry whose
variance scales like d over epsilon n
standard deviation scales like that and
if you have those matrices then the uh
spectral number you pay for it is d to
the 1.5 of epsilon n and this kind of
carries over through the algorithm in
the end that's how much more you have to
pay
so
right now it's not clear if this
has to be paid so if you just focus on
this problem of getting a
estimate or differentially private
version of your covariance matrix
do you have to pay this much or not is
an open question you don't have a
matching lower bond and we don't know if
we can improve this
but we
do something else but before i move on
if there's any question
it can do a robust estimation and the
differentially private so can i think of
it like even in the adversary uh to
learn your entry in the database
corrupts the remaining alpha fraction of
the mps they still can't learn
because it's differentially private and
robust
so what did the adversary do here the
adversary
like if i
you said if you take s and s prime which
deferred only
you can't distinguish as an adversary
right but what if the adversary tries to
change a bit of the database
yeah that is exactly what it means those
two adversaries don't have to be the
same person but let's say they happen to
be the same person they changed off a
fraction to learn the other guys but
they don't they cannot do it
that's exactly the intuition
and also if they're different guys this
guy cannot learn how this guy changes
the other data either which i we don't
have to protect but also
all right but we do something else
so does it trivialize because i mean
if the two adversaries are not colluding
still okay
i mean you said you can handle even if
the two adversaries are colluding with
each other right
if they aren't colluding does the
problem become very simple does it do no
because no first adversity you could
choose to do nothing for example you
know and then but he could
and this guy could choose to do nothing
and both of them could choose to do
something so it's
exactly a single algorithm capture all
of those
yeah okay right so so you get sensors it
doesn't trigger like this
maybe he's trying to solve the problem
so
anyway but we do something else to look
at the complexity of this problem so we
uh come up with the exponential time or
you know completion inefficient
algorithm that can uh closes the gap
so whatever is happening here the loss
is due to the fact that we want to um
polynomial
fast time algorithm
and that leads to a whole kind of new
research direction for us
so now i'm switching gears to the next
part so we
in working in this we started
thinking about
what it means uh
to have infinite let's say computational
power and look at statistical complexity
of these problems
and the end product that i'm going to
give you is called recall high
dimensional proposed test release
and it starts from a little bit higher
level motivation it's slightly different
so if you look at
differential privacy it's trying to make
sure that if you change one and three
you cannot make the output too different
and if you look at robust statistics
trying to make sure that if you change
alpha fraction of the entries the output
cannot change too much so
it almost looks like they're solving the
same problem although the details of how
you measure
privacy and robustness are quite
different
so that's the question of what is the
fundamental connection between these two
because the algorithms if you look at
those are completely different if those
that just do one of those
and this led to
a end product that we call high
dimensional proposed test release
it's a general framework for solving
inefficiently any statistical estimation
problem that we threw at it so far
with privacy
and by construction it's gonna be robust
for free
and
almost all problems with through edit
including mean estimation covariance
estimation linear regression physical
component analysis
whenever there is a low about it match
the low bound um
and whenever there's no low one it gets
the best performance among all the
existing algorithms that we know of
so here it is let's say i
and it's a general framework so i can go
to let's say needy and ask him for a
problem and let's say he gave me this
problem compute the mean with iid
samples from safeguarding diffusion with
the unknown mu unknown sigma
and the error he's going to measure it
in
his sophisticated measured number of is
norm
this is the right metric for the mean
estimation because it's kind of scaled
in variant
which is widened error if you will
um what's known in this space is that
just dp right no robustness at this
point
there is especial algorithm um
that if your sigma is in some bonded
space like identity and kappa identity
and you know this bound
then if n is bigger than some you know
polynomial d
then you can get the optimal rate
although you have to pay this in your
this assumption
so to get rid of those assumptions um
you came up with exponential time
algorithms
um in this setting the best uh that can
you can get in general setting is extra
uh error of b over epsilon squared so
there is extra one of epsilon factor you
have to pay compared to the known lower
bonds
and given this problem we want to apply
our recipe and i'll just show you how it
goes and then hopefully it'll be
self-evident that this is a
right thing to do
so you start from the aerometric that's
given to me okay
and then i do something
harmless which is i first change it to a
version that involves maximization of
all the directions which is trivial
but then i do something that's critical
to our approach which is i turn it into
an equivalent form which only involves
one dimensional statistics
v transpose mu is one dimensional
population mean v transpose sigma v is a
one dimensional population variance
and just rewriting the same thing but
once you rewrite it like this
then i can create or construct a score
function for myself because i don't know
sigma i don't know mu but i want to
minimize this so what i do i replace it
by one dimensional robust statistics
mean and the
standard deviation and i get this
construction of a
surrogate loss that i want to minimize
and what do i do next is now i have to
make it differentially private
so i sample from an exponential
distribution so that i sample those that
have smaller loss or get loss
but i have to scale it by epsilon over
delta
where delta is the sensitivity of this
score function
if i
use the right score from sensitivity
then this is guaranteed to be epsilon
zero differentially private
it's known as exponential mechanism
and the point is that i could have
plugged in bunch of different things
here the reason i chose the specific one
that i constructed in the previous slide
up there
is that using one dimensional and robust
those two have to happen together
statistics dramatically reduces the
sensitivity hence giving you the optimal
error rate
and the key ingredient in doing this
analysis in this construction it's going
to be what's called resilience property
of iid samples
that's commonly used in robust
statistics so this is where they come
together one is in the algorithm and
using robust algorithms trivial robust
algorithms are still
second is the resilience property the
kickstand
so let's do this
i'm just gonna do it for the
example of one-dimensional robust mean
estimation and show you that my
one-dimensional robust mean has small
sensitivity of one over roughly one over
n
[Music]
so here's my robust mean so in one
dimensional v given for fixed v i
project all my suppression data point
that looks like this
and because we're using nova statistic
you can throw in alpha you know
corrupted point it's fine and
everything's going to hold so i just
threw it in there and my robust mean is
cut out the top two alpha tail bottom
two alpha tail take the middle one and
take the mean of the middle part and
that's it
and this probably has small sensitivity
because
resilience tells me that the
mean of the points good points that are
caught out here
can be almost roughly you know sigma v
times
some log factor sigma v is just a
scaling of the points in this directions
it just doesn't mean much
and log is small
meaning that this guy
and the average of the good points i cut
is at most log away
meaning there's at least one point who's
at most log away and there's another one
point here that's log away so put
together there are two points one the
largest point in the bottom and the
smallest point in the top that i cut out
that are only you know this away
so that's how much
one data point can move that's effective
support
for this robust mean so the sensitivity
is probably bonded by this small thing
particular doesn't depend on the
dementia
right and the same of course holds for
the variance and you put it into our
form for the
you know score function then you can
show that this gets about order one over
n
sensitivity
but one thing
i one caveat is that all of this holds
nicely
if the data came from a sub gaussian
distribution or resilient data set
but differential privacy has to hold no
matter what data is thrown at you you
still have to be differentially private
so what people do is called the proposed
test release pioneered by cynthia dwork
herself and um you know we're using the
one that's more advanced by john woman
and adam smith and his their
collaborators it goes like this you
first
propose a particular sensitivity
according to the resilience so this part
only depends on the tail behavior of the
you know probability that you neri gave
me which was subgaussian
if it was different something else like
a kate moment bonded i'll put something
else here
and then you can privately test whether
your given data set s
um
satisfy the sensitivity for all
neighboring data sets or not there are
ways to do it and if it passes then
you're good you can use the sensitivity
so you run the exponential mechanism
that we proposed
with the
score function that only depends on the
one-dimensional robust statistics
and this
gets you um optimal error of
in this case
d over epsilon n
for the privacy
now this both algorithm and the analysis
are quite modular you can just change
the distribution and you get different
resilience you can change the problem
you can you get different score function
so you can mix and match any of those
we did that
in fact so for sub gaussian estimation
can one boundary mean estimation we get
optimal error rate using
more or less the same analysis technique
and the same you know score function
linear regression we get the optimal
rate ktm bounded
this should be linear regression
um that one there's no existing lower
bound that matches but we believe our
upper bound is optimal and you can then
for covariance estimation and principle
component analysis they'll achieve the
optimal rate
so that's kind of the power of this
approach is that there's something
fundamental about robust statistics and
pp estimation that go together well and
by exploiting it we get this general
algorithm that can be just
broadly applied
and as a by-product going back to our
original problem
that's how we get this rate with this
algorithm
and that shows that there's no gap
statistically but computationally it's
an open problem if you can close this
square root of d gap or not
great
so if you don't care about compositional
time we know how to do
these optimally not convex optimization
yet
but um if you want to do it fast we only
know how to do for mean estimation and
convergence destination and the others
are still open so please feel free to
identify the you know computational gap
and come up with the efficient
algorithms
but going beyond this there are many
practical settings that are perhaps more
important for example people have a lot
of discrete distributions um so how does
robustness and privacy go together when
you have discrete data
or
there's something called user level
robustness where each user can be
corrupted and corrupted user can give
you many
bad samples and you know uh
trusted uh user can give you many clean
data
then how does this trade-off between how
many samples each one gives you and how
many users you have it's an interesting
question and you can put it together
with user level privacy
where you can switch not just one data
point but a whole user and look at the
same previous questions
and that's i think more practical in
some settings like a federative learning
so with that i gave you the first
efficient private and robust algorithm
which you have to pay extra
statistical
cost
and i gave you a high dimensional
proposed test release algorithm which
universally applies to sexual estimation
and gets the optimal rate
the part about the efficient algorithm
is
an archive the part about the high
dimensional purpose test release will be
up on a couple of weeks
and this is a paper that i motivated
with about the backdoor attacks
any questions
i think it's time for
[Applause]
are there any questions
um contrary to maybe the beginning where
it seemed harder to achieve both
robustness and privacy together then it
was actually
easier in some sense or could they work
well together is there
the the two notions also in some sense
seem
related they're both saying that
you know you they you cannot be affected
too much by uh
uh by some users is there some notion
that actually unifies both of them not
just in terms of the method but some uh
can you
right so
the difficulty is that i think
robustness is somehow very natural
whatever people do but differential
privacy i'm not saying it's not natural
but it's very specific right you have
this pdf
and it's a specific measure it's the
infinity you know
kl divergence on this 2 metric
which that could have doesn't have to be
that right so that makes it a little bit
harder so one and essentially has
randomness built into you know privacy
robustness doesn't most of the analysis
are deterministic on the
data set deterministic algorithms are
fine
so there's a little bit of that conflict
but
yeah but this is the best you know
connection we could make though whatever
i presented
other than that i'm not aware if there's
something even you know more maybe
fundamental or deeper going on
uh how do either of these algorithms
happen when we ask for purity like pure
differential privacy or so not this
epsilon delta but
this is epsilon zero essentially privacy
and especially exponential time one
even that it just by the name proposed
as release it seems like fundamentally
it should not be possible
right so
i believe if my understanding is correct
you get one direction almost for free
and i think the epsilon zero is the
tightest one
so using exactly the algorithm that
gives you a zone zero you can get easily
you know any difference of privacy or
you know i think other difference of
privacy
easily but i don't know i presented
actually is epsilon delta you have to
pay delta because of the test proposed
and test part so that gets trickier once
you start having delta how does your
other privacy depends on the delta
is not immediately clear
as people
like delta that are really small
usually exponential in the dimension
that gets tricky then even although it's
every dependence in delta is logarithmic
i'm not sure if
it gets this idea as this gets you the
optimal one or you might have to tweak
it a little bit
um
there are no more questions for you
let's uh thanks sarah again for a great
job